okay i think it's happening
yo yo yo yo
i feel like we need to make it more
towards your side
this doesn't work
don't buy it
did they sponsor you not yet
definitely not now it's a hostage
situation
once you start [ __ ] i like how they
advertise your flag is like slightly off
yeah so it's like yeah america but still
communist because he's half the flag we
leave space open for communism
this is where we all work together and
none of us are above one another yeah
it's all about freedom and this is kim
has a following
there's not kill tony fans
that's him pandering
yeah they're uh
they're uh they're
oh they're easily red
[Music]
i know sorry guys it took forever to
figure it out
sorry uh hans isn't as smart as he looks
this [ __ ] software is [ __ ]
don't even mention software when you
don't know a goddamn thing about it the
hardware is [ __ ]
what is it hard does it sound it's soft
the medium wear
it's all about texture
he's got a lot riding on this it's the
thing why montgomery says
like when he's doing a set like
don't [ __ ] it up for me
got a lot riding on it you feel pressure
right now yeah this is really high i'm
actually relieved because i was just
like running around trying to get all
this [ __ ] set up and now it's just like
now we don't have to do [ __ ] yeah and
honestly it's like um
this is better than two cameras because
it shows
the real dynamic yeah it shows weird one
yeah
i like that when joe rogan is doing his
podcast and jamie has to go to the
bathroom and he just does the shot
it's almost like awkward right yeah
because it's like oh [ __ ] they're just
staring at each other the whole time
they're just kind of like behind a table
yeah just like in the same they talk to
me
yeah to them it's like no different from
what they were doing but to me it's like
oh [ __ ] we got a zoomed out perspective
they're actually just like cardboard
cutouts
oh joe rogan yeah well can we spread
that can we spread that conspiracy
theory he doesn't do his podcast anymore
it's just cardboard kind of the sexual
tension is off the wall
yeah if only this table wasn't in
between us
we'd be smashing into each other
uh yeah hans gets laid he says things
like smashing into each other
what did you say the other day i asked
you i said what's your love language
and
i was like
you want me to be physically yeah
aspirational my love language is [ __ ]
and vagina
yeah i don't think there's just one love
language
no i mean it has to be multiple for you
why because i have no other choice and
to diversify my portfolio yeah because
you can't read signals
that woman
was given the signal of i want to sleep
in your bed
yeah a woman literally said tans can i
sleep in your bed he said yes they slept
in the same bed and did not have sex and
then you're like oh i don't know if she
wanted to why would she ask to sleep in
the same bed
because she didn't want to sleep on the
couch the couch is like way more
comfortable if someone makes you
uncomfortable on a bed
i don't know
it's just like i we were we were like
laying in bed talking and then like i
would make lovey dovey eyes to her
oh what do those look like can you do
them
yeah never mind i get it now and then
she put her dog in between us
was it stinky no it's a tiny little 14
year old dog it's like that big it's
like an old dog
she's got a diaper on it really yeah and
she had like not even disabled no it's
just old
i had an overalls yeah you shouldn't
have had sex with this lady anyway i
have she puts her dog in overalls
yeah she would probably have like put me
in like
a
outfit like a lederhosen and carried me
around yeah sounds like she wanted to
put you in a diaper i know were you like
holding on your pants all night making
sure that she doesn't put a damper over
you and i was really afraid of that
that she was gonna take my pants off to
be fair you like left out the detail
that she put
in between uh you guys a 14 year old dog
in
in overalls
that was like a major detail you left
out i mean it wasn't the whole night it
was like part of the night so where did
it go the rest of the night the other
side
maybe she likes to [ __ ] with her dog
around maybe she's freaky
i mean i'm down for this it just didn't
happen so i'm not going to beat myself
up yeah
but also you didn't do anything to
to see if she even wanted it to happen
yeah
i did enough
i gave her the eyes actually
can you give me the eyes that you
actually gave her i was like wow so
interesting
you called her interesting
wow
i might have been in a bad mood maybe i
wasn't like
super sexual
this is almost as intriguing as two
girls one cup
but it's just so horny did you watch
that no
why not
i just didn't feel the need to
watch something gross
i didn't watch it either but i i
i feel like the reference it's actually
old now
yeah you need to get like a new record
yeah it's like 20 years old isn't there
like a new weird porn that people are
upset about no yeah it doesn't take the
internet by storm anymore yeah it's
because it's there's no king shaming so
yeah now whatever freaky thing happens
we all have to be okay with it right
yeah
like trying to find a way to make it
normal what's the weirdest
thing you've ever watched
i watched a porn where like a guy took
out like one of those dog toys that
looked like a coral reef out of a
woman's vagina
and then i i was young and i thought
like that might happen like sometimes
they're growing things oh that [ __ ]
grow coral reefs
that's why the environment's so bad
that's why climate change is happening
all the vaginas are absorbing
coral reefs yeah you guys got a queef
out coral reefs in the great barrier
reef
we can regrow the coral population that
hurt your vagina talking about this
um yeah squeezing out like a sharp
jagged piece of coral have you ever
gotten anything stuck in your penis
um sometimes they'll be like
am i right yeah
this one's
all the same you need to work on that
a dead person ah
i'm sorry
do you drink coffee
no
oh
and maybe i uh
i was just gonna suggest that maybe you
should drink coffee when you wake up
yeah
i could do that
i like the setup it looks like we're
sorted mike's even connected
can they not hear us
i don't know i don't think we should pay
attention to them okay yeah you just
have bad hearing
it's your fault
um
yeah i mean um
what else is going on you survived the
tornado yesterday was it even bad i mean
it was windy yeah it was pretty [ __ ]
crazy and they're like get inside get
inside and then for about 10 minutes it
rained
and then it was like thundering
okay can you get struck by lightning if
uh it's not making any noise like
lightning bolt noise i thought it would
make like a lightning bolt noise
well it always makes a noise that you
hear it later because it's far away
because sound travels slower than light
sometimes don't you wish that you'd just
like get struck by lightning
yeah yeah
i feel like that's probably the coolest
way to die there was a girl in my high
school whose dad died from getting
struck by my man
and like every time she told people
they're like are you serious
it's kind of like
yeah like a joke yeah it's kind of like
a sick joke what was he doing was he a
outside man
yes he yeah just an outside man he just
like couldn't stop being outside
hans is playing the long game with her
but
his end goal is clapping them kim cheeks
uh oh things are heating up and reading
these comments surrounded
damn mics are fine
that's what they said there is a wicked
it's funny because it's like um
their brains work so interestingly
do you mean hornily and ugly it's uh
their first instinct is just sex isn't
it
yeah i mean
i don't blame them but
i think it's
like they would rather be watching porn
like why don't you just watch porn it's
one tab away
that's so funny because you were so far
away from porn
but the opposite if if i was in the mood
for porn you were the opposite of what i
would watch
yeah that's the general vibe i get from
women not because you're like repulsive
but just because like
there's like nothing erotic happening
on my face
you're just like so still
yeah until i get jackhammering
it's like all still until
it's time for action and then i let out
all my energy oh my god is that where
your personality is being stored
yeah my um
in your stephen
yeah damn
um
sorry i actually can't help but see this
can you like is this does it stay
because i was going to sit there it's
kind of like moving though i kind of
like holding it
do you have an instinct to hold it
no yeah a little bit i've been touching
it a little but it makes a noise
hopefully it doesn't pick it up these
are like expensive
so hopefully they have like an inside
these are expensive can you like not
touch them you're so poor
it's your poor hands
so kylie is a comedian she's traveling
the country in her car and she's doing
it full-time
she's making money and
you know like doing comedy
so like what do you have to say to
people who are living nine to five lives
of quiet desperation um that sucks
that sucks so bad [ __ ] you you're stupid
die
that the dive
just live in a car they would probably
they would hate that that's like the
equivalent of them why
like why do people hate that so much
like they think that they're better than
that like they don't want to be
uncomfortable because people are
materialistic it's like i even thought
the things that i would be worried about
out of living out of a car it's like
i don't care at all
you know it actually just like takes you
back to your natural human instincts and
instead of like thinking about items and
[ __ ] all day you're just like oh i just
need to find a bathroom and water and
water and a shower and then i do comedy
and then it's like i don't have to think
about anything but like the normal life
is just a race to find out who can not
be concerned about survival the most so
they're all in this rat race where
they're like i don't even think about my
butthole and then like to like
completely abandon that and just do you
think you're bottle
no i'm a modern man i live in a house
now
but yeah i mean they don't want to be
connected to their body it's like a
status thing the more you're connected
to the body the more you are working
class and it's like been years and years
of civilization like we're trending
towards away from nature so like the
culture is yeah influencing us to be
like
if you think about survival [ __ ] that
means you're lower and that you're an
animal and that you don't deserve the
niceties of technology yeah
even because like even food i look at
food differently now i'm like i just
need to eat just to eat food i don't
care as much about
yeah did you try this at all when you're
living in a van like yeah you're like uh
i don't know before it's kind of like
fun to eat out and i'm like i don't
really care to do that i just like need
to eat for like
for my three meals a day and i don't
care what it is yeah it's just fuel it's
like your car needs fuel kind of like a
rocket i just like fill myself up
and then
you're not just eating big stomp stomp a
big stump all over
the town the concrete
big stomp all over the country big stump
stomp that's yeah that's my tour big
stomp stomp all over the country yeah do
haha love comedy and then now you swing
my back stop stop
titties around yeah huge titties god
it's like so hard traveling the country
with a huge tits yeah you're gonna buy
an extra seat on the airplane yeah
actually um and also do you remember
when you would cook me fish in the van
in new york it wasn't cooked it was raw
actually uh you gave you hand fed me
like you hate chopstick fed you no you
like took the entire face past your hand
it was like eyeballs and everything and
you should just down my throat and said
woman eat
yeah i caught a fish for a day dumb
woman
and i go oh my god thank you thank you
man
thank you man
yeah we used to uh hang out in my cold
van in cold new york yeah and i'd be
like oh my god are you okay like do you
need something to keep you warm at night
you're treating me like your dog yeah
disabled
yeah you're like this is a broken thing
that i can nurse back to health and then
he'll forever be in my debt and i can
use him to defeat my enemies oh my god
is that what you think of me
yeah
i often wonder i'm like what attracted
me to getting a disabled dog
trying this sex
yeah
it's definitely it's definitely more
erotic and interesting than a regular
dog
regular dogs they're just uh getting too
much for me
same old same old day-to-day
i mean i think that maybe you like
you're a disabled dog because you are
um
you know you feel disabled and you wish
someone would take care of you no
no
maybe i maybe i'm just like attributing
it to like
men i've been with
yeah
you you like to date broken people i'm
classically trained in dating disabled
men yeah i got my my degree in disabled
men yeah but not not so much anymore now
traveling around i see like all the
different people and how better people
can be
they can have like limbs that work yeah
like spinal cords
full brains it's weird i was like only
dating like one fourth brain people and
now it's like it's like almost halfway
brain
well i mean we can all be critical of
people
i mean do you really think like because
you're in new york like there's so many
interesting people there and before that
california yeah you think that maybe
it's just like
you're telling yourself that you're
getting better but
um i think i'm more open to like deeper
connection now yeah do you feel similar
i i feel like it's just like if you take
care of yourself and level up in life
and do the things you want to do then
just attract that
yeah
i haven't really been attracting
right you just like
you just like kiss people on stage and
post pictures about it so
i'm sure people you know what people
think they look at those pictures and
then they're like
taken
i'm not even gonna try he probably
doesn't want me
yeah yeah i'm sort of tired of women
it's just so exhausting just kissing
them all the time yeah it seems like
your calendar is fully booked that's why
i know it's important
um yeah i mean i guess if i'm like at a
higher wavelength then like i'm doing
more interesting things and more
interesting people
come at me and come find me
um but yeah i mean
it's like if you're at a lower
wavelength then like you're not gonna
find
the people that are at a higher
wavelength but um
i haven't really noticed that myself i
mean i feel like i've been pretty much
the same person the whole time
uh
yeah that's true you don't really um
evolve and that's not a negative thing
but you really are just like the same
person could you say the same thing
about me
um yeah i mean i think you're very
ironic and sardonic
and you're like you know you're like
aware of it all
you know you're like you can see what's
happening and you see like the zoomed
out picture and like what's going on and
then you make a joke about it just so
that it's not like
painfully aware but you like
like yeah i mean i think that um you've
always been like that
maybe it's because from your traumatic
childhood you just have to be like aware
of what's happening
so true
you called me intimidating yesterday
yeah because like you have the uh you
know what's that show the
broad city perspective
you have the uh
zendaya and euphoria perspective you're
like what the [ __ ] you're like obsidian
euphoria are so different i'm a young
woman yeah and you can you're just
judging men
that's
that's like half true yeah
but
i don't find myself to be a very
judgmental person i just don't care
yeah i mean it comes effortlessly to you
you just notice things whether you like
it or not oh that's true
that's like um
the comedian had a good joke about like
he wish that he wasn't as self-aware
because it hurts your brain
god i'm just like so painfully
self-aware it just like hurts so bad
it's intimidating because you're like
what if what if
you know this hip young woman thinks i'm
an old dumb rapist or an idiot or like a
monster we've been friends for like
three years and i've never called you a
rapist
until now
but now that you say that
now you're making it sound like i'm like
one of those like
alts people that would just like cancel
people willy-nilly
well you are a liberal
yeah i am liberal
it's just like
you are aware of like the dark side of
uh you know
men and their horniness and it's like
you can call me out on it but i also use
it to my advantage
yeah do you know what i mean
especially
like i feel
i feel well like especially in stand-up
like audience members they want to see
you for
like whatever fantasy they're trying to
fulfill you know what i mean like you're
like playing a role to them right so
it's like like jessica kirsten is like
so [ __ ] cool people are probably like
oh i want them to be my mom but then
there's like hot comics that are really
funny and they're like oh
just the idea look at her strutting on
stage she's just owning it look at that
sexy little [ __ ]
and but and i've literally noticed that
like when i was dating someone if i said
like my boyfriend
in the set like there would just be like
less people who came up to me afterwards
and asked for my instagram and [ __ ]
and so now i'm like it's like it's like
also a marketing thing like you have to
you like dangle your sexuality your
thing is like virgin or whatever
that's so sweet he's so virgin
yeah they want to take your virginity
yeah
that's what people like but then it also
puts them off because they're like oh
he's gonna be desperate and horny i
don't want to associate with that
yeah but the people who
who like you on stage i feel like
would just be like that's that's cool
who's who's calling you
desperate um myself
yeah
no i uh
i think it's good to uh you know
be aware of how your
sexuality influences the audience and
then use that
um
because i think that's a tool
and that's like a
way that people see each other and it's
the way that we interact with each other
you're like and i'm so aware that every
single person wants to [ __ ] me so badly
so as soon as i get up there
what are your jokes about
different like who's [ __ ] this girl
yeah it's hard
and then she said she wasn't a communist
ah
back to the drawing board
gotta go date in cuba
um
i
my jokes are just like sort of about you
know
how i think that there should be more
sex in the world
that's so awesome
you're like really impactful
to the bdsm
because like a lot of dudes aren't
having a lot of sex and i think that's
sad and i think if we were it'd be a
better world
a lot of dudes aren't having sex oh the
dudes would associate with maybe just
dudes in general
do you are you like trying to say that
sex should be like a priority in your
everyday life
it should be more of a priority but not
the biggest thing it should just be i
feel like it's it's like also just like
kind of complicated sometimes it's just
like we're narcissistic now and we would
rather just like not connect with people
we like the individual is the best
and then we don't like value connecting
and being a part of something larger we
just try to make ourselves awesome
instead of like trying to make the group
awesome because that's the american
thing now
yeah so i think uplifting others yeah
people don't want to connect they don't
like intimacy i think they just want to
be themselves in front of other people
well i love when people are like i'm
demisexual and that's basically like you
only want to [ __ ] people you connect
with and i'm like
that's everyone we just don't all do
that all the time i'm narcissistic to be
like i'm a god i can only [ __ ] other
gods yeah
i'm like aziz we obviously would all
prefer [ __ ] someone we like spending
time with but sometimes we don't end up
in that situation
have you ever [ __ ] someone that you
really don't like
yeah
horrible right yeah
i mean but it's like you can learn to
like someone if they you know make you
feel good
it's pretty you can learn to like
someone if they make you feel good yeah
because like that's true it becomes
toxic then sometimes but sometimes i
don't like people just off the bat
without really considering it yeah but
you don't like most people
yeah because
we haven't had sex yet but then once we
have sex i'm like oh i'm just
misunderstanding them
like this is a different way to look at
them that makes them tolerable not have
sex with them to understand why they're
worse true
it's just such a big help to have sex it
just makes me like people so much more
because they make you come
of course you'll like someone if they
make you come exactly
so it forces me to find a way to like
him oh my god
that's kind of dark what that's positive
it's beautiful
oh it's so beautiful i i hated this
[ __ ] until
she made me blow a load and then i saw
how beautiful a person
what's wrong with that it's better than
just thinking she's horrible and never
thinking she's great
it says you two are not good at flirting
what do they think flirting is
um
like what do you think flirting is
animalistic communication
when you're like oh my god hey
yeah
i want to [ __ ] you so badly i feel like
i'm just naturally a flirty person so i
don't even know what flirting is
yeah i mean i think you just connect
with people and it's not always sexual
that's true and then people make it
sexual yeah
because it's a man and a woman talking
about sex so they're like
this is them trying to [ __ ]
but it's honestly just a podcast
guys it's honestly just a podcast
between mom and dad
come on children we're not gonna [ __ ] in
front of you
no i thought that's why the camera was
set up i wish
you'd probably make a lot more money off
this
yeah give us five dollars if you want to
see us [ __ ]
yeah bed mo
they have like a super chat
on youtube sometimes they give me money
how about you kiss communications what
they give you money yeah no one's giving
me money that's the only speech that i
care about i don't care about all these
yeah i know it's hard not to look
touch my camera
okay we should stop looking
that's like your mom's house reference
but yeah i mean i enjoy talking about
this stuff
and i think like we can figure [ __ ] out
and you know maybe think about things
differently hearing each other's
perspective and sex is like such a big
part i feel like i've recently had a
different perspective with it because
before like when i broke up with my
long-term
ex um
i like came out of it and was like i
bought [ __ ] um that book the ethical
[ __ ] you've heard of it yeah um it's
like every girl that looks like me gets
it like it's fine to be a [ __ ]
why are you laughing it's fine it's
funny it's definitely fine um
but i was like reading and i was like oh
yeah it's like beautiful to like connect
with so many people on this level and
then i was like
seeing a guy and we're we're just like
being really sexually positive and
sleeping with other people together and
it was cool but then i was like kind of
like exhausted from it and then i was
like i'd rather just be like having sex
with someone that i
connect with emotionally
and then
i honestly like being on the road i'm
not like really horny that much
yeah the road
the vibration yeah the vibration while
i'm driving is enough for me i
i come all day long i'm on the road
it's just coming on the highway and it's
a health house it's a driving hazard
yeah it's pretty slippery it's
inconvenient when you're trying to like
move the seat around yeah
i got in a few accidents because of it
i mean i think that we should be
sleeping with a lot of people and i
think that
it's fine to connect with people
sexually
and i don't know if this exclusivity is
like very practical i feel like you like
talk to a buddy and we're like i'm not
getting late enough and they're like
just like put it out there that it's
okay to sleep with anybody literally
anybody that comes into the ether just
sleep with them
well yeah i honestly do think that and i
also want to have sex but it's not like
it's gross when you have sex with
someone though that you're like not that
turned on or attracted to yeah but yeah
she should be
sleeping with people you're attracted to
but it sounds like you're attracted to
everybody
yeah
what's wrong with that it's just good
it's kind of beautiful it's like
you see like
good at a lot of people yeah
except you're also like pessimistic
about this is interesting
how am i pessimistic you're like
you like you like don't generally like
people
that's not true why do you say that
like
or i guess you have a hard time like
getting close to people right
is this like something i've told you or
something you've noticed about me i
think both like the other day we're
talking about close friends in austin
too
yeah
you could use like a like a buddy
yeah i mean i think that a lot of people
are sort of
selfish
and
they
interrupt and that they don't really
know how to connect with people yeah my
least favorite people are the people who
are naturally curious like i found
myself talking to someone the other day
and it was like me just asking them
questions
and they weren't asking anything back
funny you should ask in fact in the year
2022 i uh started a small business that
like really full of themselves shark
tank and
yeah and then they send you then they
make you watch the shark tank episode
and then you're sitting there watching
the shark tank episode for about 20
minutes i hate that and then you're like
that's what they think of people is just
spectators they're like you're just here
to look at my life hey also when people
are like quoting something like
like or like when you're having an
argument that's sorry
and then they just interrupt you in the
middle of an example
no
what are you gonna say
you know when people are like
that their their like whole personality
is like quoting a tv show or like a
comedy joke or something and i'm like
that's what she said
yeah some people still do that but that
was very much like that's what she said
jokes
the hospice oh what do you mean the
office michael scott did that to an
annoying level yeah or yeah yeah yeah
um
you know
howdy duty
or like south
i never park do you know what i'm saying
oh wait keep going with them do you know
what i'm saying
it's repeating the same thing they told
me to
it's like
no it's like this handicapped guy that
talks through a little computer and he's
trying to sound gangster
yeah so
he's like
literally saying what gangsters say
do you know what i'm saying oh
but um
yo yo
when
it's like
you're talking to someone and they're
like you're having an argument and
they're just like yeah you should read
this book
uh
why capitalism is the best com yeah
it'll explain everything anyways
what do you want to talk about it's like
it ruins the conversation when you're
just like you just got to read this book
and
you'll think exactly like means yeah
yeah
it's like dude don't cheat do the work
make me think like you by
saying something in the conversation has
anyone ever successfully convinced you
that capitalism might be a good idea
um
i mean you're sort of a communist too
but you don't want to admit it i don't i
just it's not that i don't want to admit
it i just like god and
and
my political affiliation are things that
i'm too lazy to put like time into right
now do you know what i mean yeah like i
was on shrooms and
i was like yeah i feel like there's
definitely something up there or there's
someone up there or there's something
going on it's [ __ ] crazy it's [ __ ]
magical
but you wouldn't want to impart that
emotion on anyone else because it seems
like a kind of dopey surfer dude kind of
vibe yeah and i was also like it's a
it's
i don't think it's my responsibility to
find out what the what's going on here
yeah i'm mirrored just a speck on this
earth yeah you don't have any
privileged perspective over anyone else
so yeah and then with like political
stuff i'm like uh
okay the i know what i think is right
and i [ __ ] can't stand politics and i
think
with
with people affiliating with each party
is then you're being associated with
whatever that party or those people
believe and then i feel like that's
really toxic because then you can't have
your own opinions
yeah so it's like yeah i probably have a
lot of i agree because like views
our culture kind of perverts
politics and it just you know it's
ruined it's like when you're trying to
talk about something and then you have
to like fall into the lines of what our
culture has already laid out as a
groundwork for politics yeah and i don't
think it's a healthy dialogue that we're
having but
i think it's pretty easy to be like oh
yeah that's wrong that's right
you guys just think that because of
self-interest and
you your culture and what you got passed
down and the less you have of that the
better yeah that's why i like i hate
getting like mashed in with
like young white liberal
queer woman
because then it's like those are the
most virtually signally people
and there's parts of it that you hate
that are so bad but then there's parts
that are so bad of the other side too
yeah i mean i'm sure that you could sort
of shoot a [ __ ] vibe
yeah i mean it's just like our culture
doesn't have a very nuanced perspective
either you're a democrat or a republican
and it's like there's way more going on
you should be a fish we just don't
appreciate the nuance and we're just
like oh you're that but then isn't that
like sort of the goal of them
is like to make sure that you're not
politically involved to just be like
it's too complicated don't think about
it just live your life and don't make
any political changes
yeah
but i feel like i make i
in my life i have certain things that i
feel like i'm
i'm doing good for
not the world but like
in my own way yeah i mean you're totally
checked out like you don't participate
in the way that they want you to
yes that
and then with like my show i'm like
being open about something that not
people are open about especially in
comedy and my disabled dog no people
take care of disabled dogs so
it's not something that we uh
have a you know it's not part of our gdp
is like taking care of each other yeah
it's definitely like not in the
government handbook to like adopt a
disabled dog and i did that yeah you're
caring you're making the world a better
place and a happier sunnier place and uh
you think it's sunnier because of me you
think i have something to do with
climate change yeah and you're not like
[ __ ] no you're it's good to do with
uh climate and uh
positivity but yeah i mean like if you
if you're not like part of the system
like helping exxon mobil like doing
paperwork for them
uh then you're a part of positive stuff
and you know like the more people are
using their work to take care of
disabled dogs and less
um you know doing [ __ ] oh shh
on this whole time
goes on this thing
hello hello
hello hello
but yeah the more that you're actually
using your work for positive stuff
unless you're using the your work for
exxon mobil and paperwork and like
trying to sell insurance for no reason
yeah you're making the world a better
place so i think that you're doing it
but i i think that
you know it would be helped if it was
also more politically aware too
um i think my show's politically aware
is the audio better now yeah i mean
the um
the your show is like
bringing light to um
this thing and i think that
the more that we're aware of it the
better it'd be
if we were aware of like sort of the
negative side of just
the [ __ ]
better sound yay okay [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened yeah
so how are you how are you bettering the
the world
um
through your comedy
i think in a way because of like
the people that you do comedy with slash
four um
not against your will but uh they are
definitely controlling you in some way
hate my
no i don't know comrades i don't not at
all
i think it's cool and i think the
coolest part about it i think is that
you're so different from them that their
audience could use some different
perspective
and so you're not like you don't go one
way and that's cool yeah and like you're
asian like they
they like needed to have an asian person
yeah
neurodiversity and
racial diversity
i mean i think that what i'm doing
that's positive is just i'm just
expressing myself and showing people my
perspective and
it might not be much but i think that's
what i want from people is to express
themselves i think the best part of me
is the best part of everyone and i wish
everyone would just
show us what they're going through
and i think if everyone is doing that
the world would be a better place yeah i
think if you're just shutting off and
not showing people what's going on then
shitty things are allowed to continue
well someone with a comic was asking me
that's like a one-liner comic who's just
like a silly goose he was like you talk
about yourself on stage a lot how do you
do that i'm like i don't know just i've
always just done that like
it's crazy that when people aren't
personal too that i feel like don't you
feel like a sense of unfulfillment when
you're putting so much work into
something and you're not
sharing even like a tiny bit of your
perspective it's just like uh
like
wouldn't it be crazy if uh
we didn't have plates
and we're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking like why did you waste our time
yeah
but also like being silly i think is
good
yeah basically it's uh
yeah it's uh
yeah i mean some people are just so
desperate to make it that they'll say
whatever it takes they'll talk about
like random [ __ ] just because they
want to like make money from comedy but
i think if you take that out of it like
even if you're talking about plates like
mitch hedberg
like god i love i was really listening
to his album the other still his
perspective even though he's not talking
about like how many sisters he has
but he's really good at it
yeah i mean you you're trying to get
good at it he's really good at it and he
shares his perspective there's yeah i
guess also i'm talking about people that
haven't done it long enough probably to
get there if that's genuinely your
perspective and that's genuinely what
you want to talk about on stage i think
that's hilarious to be like i have this
time and attention of the country and
i'm using it to talk about farts and
poop yeah but if you're just doing it
just because you want to like
you know make money from comedy and not
have a real job
then i don't think that's an artistic
expression i think it's noise and it's
empty
and it's shallow and it's
like death yeah it's like the worst
thing yeah i guess it's like who are we
to say who's wasting your time once you
can tell
it's pretty obvious
who are we to say uh yeah we are to say
we yeah we could tell we could tell
we'll put like
you're doing comedy for the audience so
yeah the audience can tell and can be
the judge
someone said man i probably sounded like
this in my 20s yo that's so [ __ ]
annoying because it's like i was so i
was overtly politically active do you
remember that time
did you like campaign for cynthia nixon
that's so specific
it was around the time we were there no
i was just like uh
i was just
involved in a lot of activist groups and
it was just like actually
i felt that it was pretty
messy what they were doing and then
anytime they do something really stupid
like for like the gun control movement
they'd be like i think we should have no
guns and i'm like that's not the
movement
like
they're not telling you to get rid of
your guns
and then those people just [ __ ] it up
for all of us so i was just like
yeah
yeah and now you used to be more
politically active and more like what
you would call like 20s what this guy
thinks is being 20s is all about and
yeah i'm not like walking around like a
[ __ ] dumbass like uneducated these
old people they don't talk about
politics and they just keep polluting
the ocean golfing and destroying the
environment so that's not an ideal
person yeah that i'd want to be
i'd rather be aware in talking about
this [ __ ] even though it's like
we're not going to impact it right now
right here but yeah still good to talk
about and improve our political
discourse yeah i agree
so i i don't like this whole i'm better
than
you because i'm i don't talk about
politics i think from me
no that guy oh from that guy yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i mean it's like anyone can avoid
talking about it sounds like she voted
for hillary uh joke's on you
[ __ ] i'm too young to have voted
during that time
i was sucking on my thumb when hillary
was she's actually hillary from the past
he traveled in a time machine i'm
actually sexy hillary rodham clinton
came back
sorry i have mucus in my throat
rotterdam clinton
yo i had this uh
like
the epstein island [ __ ] when it all came
out with the clinton stuff i was like
that's so interesting because uh
interesting that's so interesting
because i would i would suck bill
clinton's dick monica lewinsky
yeah that's who i'm trying to manifest
that was probably before you were born
uh yeah 97 or something yeah
um but yeah 14. who wouldn't like that's
the perk of the job it's like you're the
most powerful man and you can't even get
a blow job
what kind of world are we living in yeah
don't we all want to get our uh
whoever's in office suck it he sucked
they're not going to do a good job if
their dick anchor sucks
and do we all we all see hillary she's
not going to do it she hillary [ __ ]
does not get on her knees and do that
we gotta have a president who who comes
on the wreck you know yeah
he's gonna get all pent up he's gonna
try to make guatemala suck on his dick
instead of monica yeah just like bust a
nut in monica's mouth and then maybe
maybe we'll get some [ __ ] done around
here yeah we need healthcare i like how
gingerly you did it because yeah because
i know that sound is important
um i mean i think that um
it's the ethical [ __ ] you know bill
clinton was just trying to be an ethical
[ __ ] sorry that i keep touching this but
honestly i'm just like never in a
comfortable position yeah you need to
keep moving my body's like too long to
ever be comfortable
i feel like i'm just people in general
i'm like a
fruit roll-up like that's just like
mangled and put in a small space all the
time you feel like your spine is like
my back is eroding did you know that
my lower back's eroding i think you're
fine no i have an autoimmune disease
where are my lower
it's back being a woman
um do you have like autoimmune disease
where you're like tired but then like
when you want to do something you're not
tired
um you mean bipolar disorder
yeah i have that too
um it's called sacroiliitis it's like
when our joints move like this up
against each other there's lubrication
in between it but mine doesn't have any
so it's just rubbing up against the
joints so it's just like a real thing
yeah i used to like take shots in my leg
for it and one night i woke up in all
hives and then the only people to take
me to the hospital were my roommates on
ketamine
and um
[Music]
i made it to the hospital this wasn't
bushwick
so
your body's trying to destroy you but
you're still persevering nonetheless
yeah actually isn't that poetic
that other people don't have
yeah
like when i was a kid i would want to
have a disease so that i could be like i
know i'm just
average but i'm actually
struggling really hard to just be here
so
imagine if i didn't have this disease
how much better than you people i'd be
what's your disease being
a virgin
my disease is
being
uh
awesome
which is so much better being asian
merch my disease is being awesome that
sounds like something a 12 year old
would wear
from walmart
like i see like these kids that are
trying to be jocks and they're like
i never lose and i'll beat your face in
it's like you're 12 years old everyone
on this planet can kill you
i think 12 year olds are probably some
of the most powerful groups
of people
they're [ __ ] scary
god they're so scary
12 year olds are terrifying i used to
nanny kids and the 12 year olds were the
meanest they knew how to like grind your
gears i'd find myself like fighting back
with them like i was like passionate
about it
yeah but also that might just this
probably just like says more about me
and like
i don't
envy them because they're trying to fit
into like the society that's trying to
grind them down and make them into
office workers yeah and they just like
want to like touch their dick all the
time
like they have no control on that
okay i'll take your word for it
um but yeah like nanny would like go in
the bathroom and masturbate like all day
that's what we should all be doing
like why would you deny yourself
pleasure
um but they they said like in
hunter-gatherer tribes
like kids
teenagers aren't angsty like that's a
modern thing because we're trying to
force their natural beautiful
perspective
into like a terrible society
and
kids in how to gather societies they're
like rascally they'll like
do pranks and make fun of you but they
won't like be angry and slam the door
and listen to heavy metal and blink 182.
yeah that's just our thing because we're
trying to make them do nine to five and
train them to be cubicle workers and
their natural instinct is to rebel so um
yeah i mean i don't think like
they're naturally angry and evil i think
it's like we're trying to force them and
they're fighting against it oh that's
interesting really yeah let me think
about it
i don't know because i was like i was
just like um
i wasn't really angry or maybe i was
angry i was more angry about
my family though because my family was
bad bad people
yeah
that's part of it so i like didn't even
have to like slam my door and play blink
182 i would just like
leave
yeah i'm leaving now my mom would like
kick me out of the house she's like get
out of here and i'm like i and then she
would call me like three hours later and
be like i'm calling the police if you
don't come back and i was like
[ __ ] you crazy
and then i come back and i come back
like this
that's where you got your swagger from
yo what's up mom suck my dick
and then she'll be like
ah
you're so cool
why was i never cool like you at your
age she was intimidated trying to keep
you down
yeah
you think so yeah i mean i grew up in a
[ __ ] up society i actually think my
mom probably is like jealous of
um your freedoms yeah definitely
she middle eastern
nope
yeah just a big old jew
um yeah i mean yeah my mom was in the
holocaust so she's definitely really
jealous of me
it's like you
don't have to take a shower with 700 of
your closest friends
and it's really hot shower
sometimes it's
sometimes a deadly shower
yeah that was a horrible thing that
happened
what was that laughs
i was just imagining the whole shower
and trying to get out the door and
people don't want to die
they're all fighting yeah i mean it's
horrible but you don't have sorry that i
brought the holocaust up you don't have
to know about it it's fine um i just
think that uh you know 12 year olds
you know
they're scary or whatever
can we read some of this hey hans i
found your stand up and i can't stop
laughing did she
did she just use air quotes when she
called you cool it's okay to not be
chill there is a time and place for
everything hans is going to even greater
lengths to disappoint women
damn
are you disappointed
no
yo [ __ ] you what's who is it who said
that
any
what a stupid name
what is your brother named audi
audi
ouch that would hurt
um
but yeah i mean i think that uh overall
our society is held together with duct
tape
and it can be
improved in obvious ways that everyone
can see
and it's infuriating and then everyone
is just told to not be active
politically so that
things can stay the way they are
yeah i think actually uh
like during the pandemic people were
uh politically overactive
like the people that have opinions on
everything when they don't know a
[ __ ] thing yeah
but you also find that annoying it's
like like what you were just saying is
like when people just go in on the
conversation and they know nothing about
it
so actually generally they just need to
be educated too
yeah that would help
um
yeah i mean i think that it's important
for everyone to express themselves but
also to like
be educated so that what you're
expressing is quality instead of just
garbage like yeah you went on [ __ ]
yep
um
but yeah i mean i enjoy
learning about people and connecting
with them even if they're a little
[ __ ] up and
you know that's the good thing about
comedy it's like we're all here to
connect with each other
and we're gonna have
as much positivity as possible to make
it happen
yeah and i don't think a lot of people
in comedy think that way but that's why
i love stand-up is because it's the most
interesting people because it's like you
could there could be like a guy who quit
his job
in his 40s and is pursuing state like
everyone has different backgrounds and
there's like the kid that just went to
college and
um
everyone's from [ __ ]
every different state that yeah
and just wanting people that want to
talk yeah they just like and they like
need to talk yeah which is cool
yeah sometimes the people that need it
the most aren't the best at translating
it into something usable yeah like
sometimes they need to talk to like a
professional first sometimes they're
[ __ ] up
um
and the like yeah they're like
barely keeping it together
do you feel [ __ ] up i wouldn't like
identify you as a [ __ ] up person
um yeah i mean i found my identity and
rebelling against the system so
i've tried to
harness my [ __ ] up-ness
but i think it's healthier to rebel
against the system than to just go along
with it you know what's funny too
because like when you're living in a van
in new york everyone's like it was
[ __ ] crazy and then the pandemic
happened
and like everyone
started moving into vans and [ __ ]
and they're like oh maybe this was a
good idea after all
living in new york full-time in a van is
pretty crazy though
i couldn't imagine that really during
the winter and stuff
yeah i mean
i mean you didn't have a heater and [ __ ]
but for the longest time i didn't have a
heater
um but yeah i mean
it's like
the the day-to-day concerns aren't that
important it's like the overall
what i'm telling myself i'm doing the
spiritual journey that i'm on is way
more important and i couldn't
suffocate my soul inside like sunset
park 45 minutes from downtown yeah
having to work like that is way way
worse than the physical discomfort
that's how i feel now too even like
paying
a landlord that doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you and doesn't fix anything and
just like giving them
money that just goes down the drain
yeah
and they have like plenty of money and
they don't give a [ __ ] about you yeah
middle man
yeah it's it's a [ __ ]
yeah and so
yeah i'm over it
yeah that's what the pandemic was good
for people were like oh i could die
let me figure out what the [ __ ] i'm
doing better quality of life let me move
to ohio you see those ads for ohio it's
so crazy jesus it there i saw an ad the
other day where it was like
move to ohio you're going to be inside
working all day anyway
[Laughter]
i was like not really shooting all right
at least they were honest about that one
the moon they're just like we're just
sort of there
it's better we're just like cheaper
because we're worse
yeah you'll not be close to anything
awesome but hey at least you don't have
to work as hard
um but yeah i mean i think the pandemic
was good because it taught us like to
have another perspective and not just be
focused on some [ __ ] yeah
i agree you really want to die
coughing at a [ __ ] call center
like yeah go live your life and
they also it's also people saw behind
the economy they're like oh you can just
give us money yeah you don't even need
us to come into work you just you just
made me do that so that you could
control us that was the [ __ ] up thing
i didn't do was i collected for like two
months and then i went back to working
because i'm
so stir crazy um
and so this is my first time in my life
where i'm actually just focusing on
comedy and like
sometimes when it feels like i have too
much time on my hands i'm like oh no
it's just because i'm used to
breaking down my body 24 7 and working
my ass off and grinding in new york city
yeah we're used to that so it's like
normal to be miserable we're just so
used to so much
terrible feelings and then you start
traveling and you see how how better
quality of life is everywhere else yeah
and just like people are nicer
yeah but i mean like the rust belt towns
aren't doing that good either like the
towns are there's no jobs and everyone's
on opioids
yeah
um
yo that shit's tight
my friend who grew up in like upstate
new york
like all of her friends just casually
did heroin
and then they none of them went to rehab
or anything they just like grew out of
it
it's not the craziest [ __ ] you've ever
heard yeah
you can use all like think drugs no more
heroin
yeah you can do it you don't need to
[ __ ] pay money
to go to a place
have you ever been addicted to anything
yeah
yeah babes
is that what you think
an alpha male would say uh yeah yeah i
definitely think you're an alpha male
well my character is on stage
no um
i think addiction is like
there's
a lot of different types
have you experienced any starcraft 2
uh weed
you know different things i just don't
think addiction is like a helpful way to
look at things
i think underlying addiction is trauma
that's what gabor mate says
and i think that we should address the
traumas in our society instead of just
like
stop doing the thing that brings you joy
yeah
but some people actually like can't
handle it yeah
ruins their life yeah physically
chemically but we should stop that
before it happens and usually you can
stop that by
giving you know
like a living wage and making sure they
have home and shelter and food yeah but
what's your advice to the people that
are already [ __ ] up
um well keep doing heroin
like your brain means it if you stop now
you'll die so don't stop
and then like god that's great advice
rebel against the society that you live
in and improve it politically by
having like you know like a charity
where they give out bread and food and
heroin on a large scale and then that's
called communism
uh yeah but also charities are [ __ ] up
well they are in our current
economic system because you need money
yeah
but it doesn't have to be that way the
concept of charity can work but it's not
necessary if we just pay everyone a fair
wage then we don't have to have charity
i watched a whole video about coney 2012
last night
that [ __ ] was crazy do you remember that
yeah you were like
10.
no i was i i can tell the the year about
the age by my year or oh my god did i
just have an aneurism my age
the age by my years my age by the year
so i was 12.
oh and i was like changing my face but
kony 2012. yeah there's a lot of
positive emotions in the world and
unfortunately the only thing we value is
profit so it's gonna be perverted for
profit
whoa did you just like roll up your
sleeve to show the fans your big ass
arms yeah damn
wait why are you hiding it now because i
was trying to scratch in it do you think
i have
a more muscley arm are you
um
i think mine is yours is bigger
hans just called me fat
you're fleshy
i'm fleshy yeah oh my god this is why
you're not getting laid what the [ __ ]
bro you just call me fleshy this is not
about getting laid this is about
accurately describing arms because you
decided to compete it's not fleshy
it's like it's not jiggly
my arm is not bigger than yours or maybe
it is
i don't know is it no your arm is more
muscly than mine mine's just like a
little noodle exactly that's what i was
saying i mean flex i said it was bigger
yeah i think maybe it might be
i think it's pretty close
i need to work out
okay i'm gonna go home and chop my arms
off after i said home i'm gonna go in my
car and chop my arms off
but do you like the freedom don't you
feel like you're better than people
you have a purpose i don't feel like i'm
well i've always felt like um
i'm a little bit special with how my
brain works and what i have to offer and
like my work ethic
and that i'm capable of like living out
of the car and just like
doing whatever i want with it
it's like i can go wherever i want and
bring my show to whatever city
and so i definitely feel like i'm living
a way fuller life than most yeah and
people lack what you have
like they have nothing and you have
everything
in terms of spiritual fulfillment like
they have no idea what it's like yeah i
mean like there was in california my
bank account was like [ __ ]
at zero at one point and i was not
stressed at all and like in new york
when i was living a normal ass life and
i would
i would uh
i would start running out of money it
was so stressful and i was like
no i mean i'm working like i knew that
money was coming from my shows too but
i i just like
have less concern about things because
i'm doing what i want to do that i like
you're using money and jobs as a tool to
live your life instead of using your
life as a tool to
work a stupid job that's not going to
matter in 20 50 years yeah
god i've had like a million jobs ever
since i was 14 and like
i was when i first moved to new york i
was working at a coffee shop like 35
hours a week i'd make like
400 bucks in two weeks which is like
nothing
for that much work and in that city
and i was like what is this [ __ ] and
then they'd also be like you gotta get
the phone right on the [ __ ] latte you
stupid [ __ ] and i'm like don't like i
could [ __ ] this cup of coffee up because
you're paying me actually like five
dollars an hour you stupid ass
yeah they're trying to squeeze every
value every cent out of you by
emotionally torturing you
um
yeah
the
yeah i feel like um
barista jobs also have gotten like um
like glorified
like so they can pay you less yeah like
it's hip and cool yeah to be [ __ ]
poor
yeah from
working your tight little ass
yeah
yeah that was so funny working in new
york city and service jobs you're just
working with other artists all the time
that are just so
sad
yeah
this is our economy you can't just do
art
did you ever uh
work in service yeah yeah you worked at
a sushi restaurant right yeah
i worked saying hi to people
i got paid decently like 17 19. you got
free fish yeah that's not bad yeah but
it's still
not something that humans should be
doing for their whole life
no like this is not fulfilling some
people like doing it though i like
bartending that's your thing but we
shouldn't force everyone to find meaning
and serving people food no yeah and then
you have to like everything's good when
people are [ __ ] to you
yeah
the emotional toll of that is
high especially working at a dive bar in
new york city as a woman and when you're
in comedy as a woman too
the like
the [ __ ] i would have to put up with i
just i was like i'm actually not gonna
put up with it anymore because that
whole job is just like sexualizing too
yeah
which is dope if you're making a lot of
money yeah you're just like the face
stop looking at the chat i'm sorry it's
so hard it's like no my face is so
boring they have such interesting things
to say like no they don't like damn
damn kim that's all i have to say it's
like what
i would never feel obligated to type
anything watching a video
well it also not sexually abuse
waitresses at dive bars oh yeah
um but yeah i mean
it's like
i mean what only people they talk to all
day
that's like uh it's so funny because
when you serve people at bars too like
you start to see them like get more
intoxicated
and like more
in this false reality of like oh this
bartender must really like me because
they're talking to me and it's like no
that's just my job
i know but like once you you can't keep
telling yourself that yeah and
eventually you're just like oh no she
just likes me yeah and then there would
be times where i'd make like a [ __ ] ton
of tips because i'd talk to them and
like i would just be myself
which is like kind of like sarcastic and
like
that they're like oh my god a girl is
like like talking back to me and being
like sassy and has a sense of humor
that's so hot and i'm like no i'm just
like really dry i'm not trying to be hot
right now but i'll take the tip just
conversing you're excellent at the art
of conversation but i think it'd be
better if like there are more
conversations happening but like people
don't want to converse with people
because they're afraid it'll turn into
something more intimate i love
especially with traveling intimacy i
love just like talking to random people
yeah you can tell and make this podcast
is all about yeah he's we've never met
before i literally just was walking by
your house and i peed in your front lawn
and i was like and you came out and
you're like what are you doing and i'm
like oh my god do you have a podcast i
could be on yeah you want to sit in this
chair for an hour while i'm trying to
figure it out
that was uh yeah that was a
disappointment how
you didn't figure it out and we spent
all that time
yeah i don't know what's going on i
might have to return it but the camera
no the little oh the
it's so crazy i have to pay 180
just to connect my [ __ ]
should i come
you know it should be a part of the
thing it's like the ability to connect
to a laptop but whatever
um yeah i mean i think it's uh [ __ ] up
how
the service industry works and how
like you are the
lube of the commercial sector yeah you
just like talk to people and make them
okay with them spending money and
without you the whole thing would
crumble
but yeah and then you keep customers
coming back
and you are the human face you do the
things that uh the ceos
can't do and won't do
that are actually like the human element
of the company and
uh and they you should get more money
for that like you should be paid fairly
for the profit that you give
you bring in instead of like the lowest
minimum wage possible i feel like
sometimes when i listen to you talk i
feel like you've
you've like rehearsed this in the mirror
the day before because it just flows out
of your mouth so easily
but it's so many words
i am listening i'm also admiring the
fact that
there's so many words just flowing out
of your mouth and you're not making a
single mistake
what the [ __ ] it supposed to be
listening to like what i'm
doing yeah
what you're saying okay but it's also
hard to listen to what you're saying
when it's like
no you're like a human machine
what is this [ __ ] i'm just trying to
convey the ideas in my head and no i
like it like it's
good for you but it's insane that you're
not even stuttering like am i talking to
a [ __ ] robot right now
what's happening trying really hard to
keep it together are you really more fun
are you really trying hard to keep it
together right now you're so relaxed
it's hard to tell if you're doing
anything at all
or do you feel any emotion right now
yeah i feel like put on the spot i feel
like you feel happy exposed do you feel
excited i feel good yeah it's fine
do you feel love for your friend kylie
yeah
kyrie kalei
kylie minogue um
okay sorry what were you saying human
machine copied facts back it back it up
[ __ ] that's what you were saying um
stenographer i was saying like um you
are like as a service industry you're
like the
you're like the nice soft
coating around the wire mesh of a
corporation yeah
and uh you know that's valuable
they're like young and tight yeah put
young and tight right right where the
capitalists want them
yeah
you're the face do you think they have
like a book in the white house where
it's just titled young and tight and
it's all about
young and tight servers and bartenders
that are keeping the economy stable and
thriving
they're like we need to keep this crop
of young tightness
how do we get more young and tight
americans
on the front line and tighter and
tighter
how do we tighten them up
so tight
that there's no more room that's so
funny that's like some cardi b self-talk
we're like uh-huh i'm so tight
i say it on stage all the time that's
weird i think it's funny that uh
you're informing someone
of your tightness or
looseness
yeah that's like what you think is
positive about yourself but
nobody's actually thinking like that
yes my brain is beautiful
but that sounds amazing pressure to be
attractive that manifests it's like
i don't have pressure to be attractive
obviously i just am
yeah i mean i just be
no i pretty much woke up and
put a little glitter on your eyeballs
yeah but no i just like i truly
especially uh being on the road and
stuff i'm just down with more natural
[ __ ]
and i feel like that manifests in the
best way too because if you just are who
you are and you're confident about it
that's
i'm attracting the right people
yeah or i'm attracted to the right
makeup isn't that attractive all the
time yeah some people do too much and
then like i see them without it and it's
like you look exactly the same
yeah i think it's more of a creative
thing
like
for me i i put on makeup because i have
my show tonight and it's just like i
think it's appropriate on stage so they
can see your features better but that's
like the theater in me
um
otherwise
but it's normal for women not for men
yeah normalize putting makeup on um
specifically hans kim
yeah we should start a movement we need
to cover this face up with
paint but don't you think it's like if
you don't wear makeup then you force
yourself to be naturally more attractive
and if you put makeup on all the time
you're like your eyebrows go away and
then your skin can do whatever
and you can just paint over all of it so
you don't really try it
as hard maybe i don't wear makeup that
often so i don't think about it
i'm like the only i i
like the way i look and i'm happy with
it and i'm confident and i'm so 2022 to
just be like paint over it it doesn't
matter what's on the inside yeah the
only thing that sometimes bothers me is
uh like i have cystic acne scars and i
think that's like fair
to be like that's not
i mean if you can cover that up i love
it i've come to terms with it and i'm
like i love my cystic acne
it's actually so hot
but
i think it's cool like sometimes you
want to like dress up a little bit who
gives a [ __ ] like don't judge people for
doing whatever they want how does it
affect you i honestly don't judge people
for wearing makeup i think it looks
really you said people look uglier with
makeup on
i said that you called people
sure to
oh yeah there's definitely pressure
you know like if you didn't wear makeup
maybe it would make you like try harder
in a different way
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know i was always raised
like
to kind of be left to my own devices and
i think being raised in southern
california where everyone's like really
pretty and skinny too like when i was a
kid i tried to do that but then i was
like i'm just like a [ __ ] like i just
like
natural
i
there's something about authenticity
that maybe
isn't that prevalent in south southern
california no
and maybe you crave that more than this
thing that you see all the time this
fakeness yeah
yeah i think i i just like if you're
also with nature and not to sound like a
big old hippie but
i'm like it actually literally doesn't
make sense to wear makeup or nice
clothes if you're in nature all the time
yeah and i feel like once you have the
sun it's beautiful it just makes you
beautiful you notice how you go on the
sun i don't know if you experience this
i get a big glow afterwards i'm like i'm
a hot sexy lady
after the sun yeah
i guess i do that too i want to be
attractive too i just don't think about
it that way but yeah the sun is great we
should be out in the sun more
um but yeah where our faces are designed
for fluorescent lighting and
it's uh you know we're specialized or
like a
goddamn you know
like a
goddamn
thing that's specialized for inside and
not outside
we're specialized for inside not outside
yeah not you specifically as the human
population i don't think so i think
humans are made to be outside well we've
been spending inside we've spent most
our time inside for 10 000 years yeah
and in offices and shaking hands and
making deals
well that's what we've evolved into i
guess but
that's why i like austin because it's
like our outs it pushes you to be
outside more it's like an outside city
yeah we should have done this podcast
outside
[ __ ] you're right we look like a bunch
of posers we're like oh yeah outside is
so much better than we're just like in
your [ __ ] gray room that's a box yo
but you took the cardboard off and the
sun is shining through and that's
i bet you don't do that too much
why are you looking at the messages
i don't i didn't i don't really care
about it as much as you do if you
couldn't tell no i'm just interested in
it because i also don't know how people
think of you because i just know you i
don't follow this world of you oh yeah
yeah i don't either i just see like the
[ __ ] you post on facebook but i
otherwise i don't watch the show or i
don't interact with
instagram that much
i mean people seem to have an idea of me
and it seems generally positive but i
don't really try to go out of my way to
and i don't think you should because
then i feel like it's your whole then
it's like
all you think about it but if
you do care how do i change their
perception of me yeah if i do
this thing a lot
of you know maybe if i
i scratch my head they think i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] cool and crazy yeah
politically active like actors
maybe if i use my hands more they'll
think that i'm politically active
i mean i'm not that politically active i
barely give any money to homeless people
i was thinking about you that the other
day about how you don't like homeless
people
how do i not like homeless people i was
one
yeah but you're like a glorified
homeless per i don't like i wouldn't say
that right like i say that as a joke
like homeless but uh it was like our
choice yeah
it's not like some of the other homeless
people
um but uh what what is there a specific
instance where i showed my hatred of the
homeless
um
[Music]
yeah one time you you like spilt hot
cheetos on a homeless guy in new york
city and you kicked him and you said
eat hot cheetos [ __ ] and i was like
hans i'm hans are you i don't know
what's serious or what's a riff that's
definitely a lie
but um
i don't like homeless people like
interacting with them but i don't blame
them for their
problems i mean some of them i do blame
but like i think mostly it's
socioeconomic
yep
you're always going to have a lower
class
i mean uh
austin doesn't really have
i haven't seen many homeless people here
where are they
they're around i mean austin is kind of
known for its homeless population
haven't seen him
usually i give him like a fist bump or
something
oh wait we should we should talk about
how that wallet we found the other day
oh yeah we found a wallet i found a
wallet on the curb
and i pointed it out to you and then i
picked it up and i was like we have to
return this yeah and you were digging
through it we found out he was a pedicab
driver in new orleans we found out that
he his last name was law and i was like
is he a law student or that's just his
name
and then someone got in the picture it
looked like he had brown or black hair
he just had like a like a ginger fro and
he kept he came on walking up and i was
like you and then he's like he instantly
hugged you yeah he grabbed the wallet
and then he hugged me and then he gave
us fifteen dollars
and we had a little conversation he
pulled out he was like pulling out cash
counting the cash as if it was he was
gonna like hand us a hundred dollar bill
because he was like thank you so much
thank you then he hands us fifteen
dollars and i'm like
that was a lot he had like twenty five
dollars in his wallet
okay that's
no i mean i pro like he didn't need to
give us anything yeah but uh
15 is offensive i think
well you know we could have just left it
there and he could have kept all that
money and he could have found it himself
yeah because he did come back right well
or someone else maybe timing is
everything those 10 seconds after we
would have walked past it someone might
have taken it and taken it forever
he's lucky that we found it and we're
suburban children he's lucky that we're
his guardian angels and we're big
[ __ ]
yeah we're such [ __ ] if we were
strong and tough we would have stolen
that guy's wallet yeah we would smart
and finally
go get reese's with his credit card and
then it instantly notified that
someone's trying to get reese's at a
smart and final and then make him get a
new license even though we don't really
need a license we got his
and then we become pedicab drivers in
new orleans
oh my god that'd be a crazy job
yeah
damn do you like new orleans yeah i
think it's good i like what it
represents you know we can't have every
city be like [ __ ] you know boring and
drab yeah we need a city where it's like
how how y'all doing
wrong
knowledge is that a southern iceland
y'all yeah you're good you're young and
doing good over there
oh my god
i just want to like put a bonnet on you
while you do that accent can you do that
again with a bonnet on like a little
house on the prairie yeah
new orleans new orleans beignets and
[ __ ] i do declare
i don't know how to do it when they call
you like sweetheart or something yeah
and they talk about the dead bodies that
are buried underneath the city and that
it really smells during the summer
because they rise to the top the heat do
you hear about this spooky city yeah i
like spooky cities yeah i love it you
know it's different
we need different cities we can't have
everything be like houston just like
paved with highways
and [ __ ] everywhere
i can't believe uh people still think of
houston
i don't think of houston when i think of
cities like
l.a famous for being badly designed yeah
it's just paved and you can't walk
anywhere and you have to have a car and
traffic is horrible and the highways
have 17 different exits
in one exit and you have to choose the
right one
it's like me the other day like the
u-turn
how [ __ ] u-turns here it's like la's
also built like [ __ ]
you like you stop at a stop sign before
you get on the freeway so you're at zero
miles per hour and then you instantly
have to merge on the freeway at 55 miles
per hour what is that [ __ ] and then
you 55 miles per hour and then it's
instant traffic so you have to go zero
again real quick and like
yeah
and it's so inefficient to just pave the
entire road whereas like a railroad
it's just two little tracks and then you
can put like a hundred people on it
at a time yeah like you can swerve all
over the road it's like i don't need to
be able to do this i just want to be on
a track
i don't want to be able to have this
much freedom
are you so you're this is a pro
public transit conversation now yeah of
course i mean
yeah it actually makes no sense when
you're in a city and it's a driving city
yeah even san francisco i was i was
losing gas like no but
dude those hills if i had any eggs that
were left to fertilize in me they're
gone now because going up those hills a
[ __ ] egg killer you know what i mean
on a bike
no i was not biking in san francisco how
are you losing eggs in a car so bumpy
and like big bumps in here
and i was like i will never be able to
get pregnant
maybe for the best you should not be
sitting on a dildo while you're driving
dude but that's what they told you to do
as soon as you enter the bay
you go through a checkpoint and they
give you a dildo they give you a lesbian
for your pleasure yeah
harvey milks dildo
[Laughter]
it's just a jug of milk
what does boofing milk mean it means
drinking it through your vagina or
[ __ ] really yeah
why does your does your vagina all the
sudden get like a
instinct to like sip up or do you have
to like
like connect a wire
a tampon soaked in milk
you're just like just like put a usb
drive and like connect the milk to it
and then have you ever milked a cow yeah
does it feel good
a little bit
it feels like i want to milk a cow yeah
it's like something soft that you're
supposed to touch really it's like made
for us
yeah now it's all machines so
what about uh tipping a cow
that's rude yeah but have you done it no
i'd rather touch its tits
some may say
tipping it is
less rude than touching its tits
does that cow have a shirt that says
milk my tits
or does it not
this is some of the famous
riffs that happen at riley's house
oh my god do you hate that i just went
into a bit
hans is anti-comedy i don't know if you
guys can tell this but um i mean anyone
can just detach from reality
i feel like i'm having like a really
good conversation with you and it's
normal to also want to joke a little bit
okay the cow is wearing a shirt it's
actually suffocating if you're like
don't joke during this conversation
about communism
like how am i supposed to love my
there's also balance like you need to
appreciate balance and incorporate that
in your life too
like you're allowed to be magical you're
allowed to be funny too sometimes like
you don't have to be deep all the time
that's exhausting humor i just wish it
was like more
you know like directed at something
concrete instead of just like a cow
wearing a shirt yeah who gives a [ __ ]
it's like don't you like silly things
yeah what about it how funny is it
thinking about a cow wearing a goddamn
shirt and then there's like a pink
dildo inside of the box yeah you're an
[ __ ] because i was just like talking
about driving in san francisco you're
like were you on a dildo well you said
you lost yeah
how are you losing eggs unless there's
something sharp pointing directly at
your ovaries
uh
hans thinks girls are not funny he's
pretty rude sorry i know i'm not
supposed to look at this but that is
that is that's funny that i just read
that girls are not funny girls are not
funny and i will die on that hill
there's just something biologically
about girls that make them not funny you
know i think that girls are hilarious i
think that they have a different
perspective honda's like i think girls
are hilarious as long as they have sex
with me
that helps
but
i think that like uh
i'm funny
i do yeah i think you're hilarious i
think you're very um aware and you're
like
anyways i laugh at myself a lot oh my
god i laugh at myself a lot you're
crowder your crowd work is excellent
because you like take in whatever they
say you don't like reject it you like
fully
take it in and then you like process it
and then you move on
like for me i sometimes have a hard time
be like taking it in i'll just be like
you're an idiot why are you
oh i appreciate that that's actually
really nice um yeah i kind of like black
out when i do crowd work it just like
comes out of me like
i feel like i'm
i like died and then i come back to life
yeah you're like you just like that's a
crazy thing to say anyway yeah
i'll totally yeah you want to you know
[ __ ] me or something i also feel like
because in the beginning i used to get
mad at people also and it's just like
such a turn off to the crowd that like
it makes you listen to them and you're
like wait
actually this is an opportunity for me
to like look really funny and smart yeah
if i listen to this yeah but do you not
do crowd work i do i just like to do it
like with a purpose and for a reason i
don't like to just do it yeah just to do
it i would say like my style is pretty
chaotic and i'll just like weave in and
out of it but i also just think that's
probably one of my like best skills in
comedy so i like doing it yeah um i mean
you're an empath you feel things
is that what you gather for my crowd
work yeah
that's so true my friend was making fun
of me and he was like
uh like like we love when you laugh but
like do it a little less because
then it's you're stomping on your punch
lines and i'm like i'm just having so
much fun up there though
i was like doing a
a bit about guns and i was like oh guns
he's like you look [ __ ] stupid up
there
um but yeah when i hit like a good place
on stage i have so much fun yeah i'm
like i feel like everyone should feel
that way
yeah
you should
yeah it's you should be happy you don't
want to look miserable
but i feel like there's a balance
because if you're too happy then
you're going to get in the way of your
performance yeah
but i'm sure you
you can find the balance
eventually do you look happy on stage
sometimes
are you happy on stage yeah
it's love sometimes i love it
sometimes i'm like i don't know who
these people are
and i don't
think they deserve to live
yeah and
that's a crazy thing to think when
you're on stage
i know funny that's like a school
shooter
mentality
well
yeah i mean um it's sort of misanthropic
and negative and you know yeah like a
cloud of despair hanging over my head
but usually i try to avoid that
yeah i think you should also try and
avoid that yeah you need to stop being
so happy and i need to stop being so
murderous
uh it's a like uh
weird when i do my solo show because i'm
like talking about my life for an hour
and then it's like
when you can see people's individual
faces and you're like you're just gonna
know every little thing about me
and then if they're like not on board
with what you're saying you're like but
it happened i don't know it's like
really difficult doing
an hour that's not just stand up and
building tension and breaking it with
comedy because uh
if you build that tension and don't
break it with comedy that [ __ ] hurts
yeah that's really difficult in like
limbo they're like
we still have it yeah someone will leave
us yeah they just like want to be like
punched in the stomach with something
funny and sometimes it's like i can't do
my solo show every single day like stand
up so it sometimes i literally just have
to work it out while i'm doing it and
like eat [ __ ]
yeah
that's the audience is like oh [ __ ] you
know like there's a there's a lot on
love on the line in a live performance
you got people's attention and emotions
wrapped up
and uh you know that's the things that
that's the thing that makes the world go
around
is people's ideas and emotions and you
can't have it in the palm of your hands
crush it
but they also have defenses where
they're like oh this guy's full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
yeah there's like um for some reason i
imagined you talking about this like you
have like figurines
at home
and you're like
you're like have audi like little
figurines of audience members
and you're like have a figurine of
yourself doing stand-up and you're like
my bit and then
and then you like go back and forth with
them and that's how you
practice like a god like playing with
little voodoo dolls yeah oh my god
that's that'd be a great movie
it's like a red edition of joker but
just like uh
more autistic
uh the the plot that's changed is he
just loves playing with dolls
thank god it's an outlet for him
he's not so angry
i kind of have to pee
you want to read one comment okay
should we uh end it or do you want to
how long has this been going on
um an hour and a half
how long do you usually do it for
an hour
oh i've
then maybe we should end it i mean they
kind of love it like why do they [ __ ]
love us
yeah look at all these emotions oh my
god all these emojis mitochondria it
means that they're like really emoting
should put up a saudi flag
stand up and traveling preachers
yep
self-identified traveling preacher
surprise something that we talked about
that now i don't know what it's in
relation to
got milk
that was probably when you were talking
about milk and cows
why were you talking about milk again
uh putting it up my [ __ ] i think i know
what but of course
oh yeah
edge queen overlord that's so funny do
you think i'm an edge edgelord
no
you're too liberal to be an edgelord
okay maybe hans is going
to blow her unprompted
that's sick they're so horny that's so
funny like
just pee dead
i know i'm about to pee my pants
should i end it
okay i'll just i'll just pause it
wait now we look really cool
the hat and the neck pillow
i'm gonna say i'm republican now
[Music]
you're a trucker boy
i know you're hungry but i'm gonna wait
another hour to eat girly
come here
curly poo you want some sausage
come here really damn you didn't even
ask me if that was okay psycho what's a
dog
i don't feed her human food
because then she'll become a beggar
that's so sad
i really hate his human food
yeah because you're
human because you're home on you don't
want to share our culture with the dog
um
no i i i don't want her to steal the
the limelight william
we're already back yeah
smile more
stop reading the comments
yo sorry
yo i look [ __ ] cool do you want to
freestyle yeah okay put on some beats
royalty free beats
youtube
my god
one hour that should be long enough
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he's so thin
thin as his butter and his licorice
twist bit up in the [ __ ] hey
is
[Music]
oh
i like the taste of food
like eminem's in
and
and and cool food okay wait
yeah
here we are with an american flag that's
what you call it if you don't have a dad
i don't have a dad i think you have a
dad but don't talk to him because you
just are kind of a bleep
[Applause]
i can say it because i've eaten [ __ ]
before
i love my dad more than you even know i
think he's really rad i think
can you hear me now i'm [ __ ] rapping
everything you do is all the copping
[Music]
oh this dog looking at me hungry cause i
know you don't feed him because you're
out here like up hungry
i'm yo that looks kind of good
okay um
yeah yeah
yeah no no keep going wait training to
be
we need to change the vibe in here
this is a horrible beat
that's free
yeah
uh getting mochi powder all over my
favorite [ __ ] hat
what are you thinking about you are a
bat
you you're uh you're fat
hans called my arms fat earlier he said
i was a girl
in her and and he doesn't have girls in
him because he is a little boy and he
can't even finger him
because he doesn't know how he don't
know where the [ __ ] is he just knows
where to put his foot in
love footing [ __ ] up and down with my
toes uh that's what i do to these hoes
they don't even know but i put him in a
bow then i take him out in a boat and i
row
and
in the snow he pees in it he drinks it
he uses it for
fertilization
okay rhyme with fertilization yes you
can who says who says huh
hans kim
is the greatest there ever was
said no one ever
oh
kylie vincent
she lives in a car what a loser i would
never want to do that unless i was a
boozer
and that's what i do i go up and down
and talk to chicks every day and i
use my dick i talk to chicks every day
and i use my dick and make them suck it
and then they say yo [ __ ] it i'ma suck
dick
can we be over
with this that's what i wanted for a
while
did they even hear that that's a wrap
you do when you're drunk with friends
and board
hans kakia tori
anyway why did they barely have anything
to say about it
i don't know
but um
what are you uh
what are you gonna do tomorrow
what am i gonna do tomorrow yeah you
have your show tonight check it out
theater
tonight yeah because they didn't sell a
lot of tickets and um they just let me
know that and i'm like i don't want to
perform for
less than 20 people yeah
hey uh come to the fallout theater
tonight no no it's not their vibe
it's not you don't want my followers to
follow you no that's insulting you're
insulting me now followers should stay
in their own pig pen
i've got a no you guys can follow me on
instagram just don't follow me around
but buy tickets give highly your money
you could buy tickets so i could get the
money i'm just not gonna show up
yeah take a risk support this is like
she's like bitcoin right now you gotta
invest early uh i'm gonna nft my sexual
assault
did you record it
no no no just the fact that i've been
sexually assaulted i'll just make that
an nft
you just saying that on video right now
well we're 21 people oh there's only 21
people on yeah that's enough
you need 20 yeah if you guys all rally
out tonight
so what do you think about comedy and do
you think that it's
uh
you know is is it like a good enough art
form is it should there is it like is
there a limit to it um i think
you can make it whatever
you want it to be and when people think
of comedy they usually have like a one
single brain vision of it and then they
get mad when you do something a little
bit different but you can actually do
whatever the [ __ ] you want with it
and um stand up i think just in how it's
structured for showcases can be limiting
because in
what are you doing i'm trying to see if
i'm on a show tonight you are on that
show the show that i'm on too
but you're not on it i'm like on it but
not on it
yeah she was like i'm gonna put you up
but here's how it works
and i was like what i might not put you
up yeah
so it's like pretty big deal stand up is
hard
um you know it's like
independent but you also need people to
book you and you also need to be like a
part of a scene
and some people don't do well with that
i mean i'm kind of a social butterfly
i'm really good at talking to people and
making them comfortable
so it's a little different for me but
yeah i mean um yeah you gotta get to
know people and like you have to have
them approve of you and you gotta
have them book you on your shows on
their shows but i mean you did the same
where you book your own [ __ ] so
it's i just canceled my shop
i don't want to perform for less than 20
people it's demeaning for what i have to
do exactly yeah you got to take care of
yourself yeah
um
but yeah i mean
you are doing your own show and you
don't need other people to book you
anymore but they still do but yeah you
took control and you're like i want to
go out there and i want to do shows and
you you're not just waiting around for
someone to help you and
do everything for you you're just like
i can do this my all i need like anyone
else would just be a middleman
you don't need anyone else
and people don't want to go out and talk
to people they want riches and money and
fame
they don't actually want to talk
they don't want to actually
do what comedy is and can communicate
with people yeah
wait so are you saying like
people don't actually are you saying
like people are in it for the wrong
reasons
i'm saying
people are not
uh independent
they're weak and they need other people
to help them but
you don't need other people to help you
you can do it all yourself if you have
the gumption
and the ability to do it i mean i i was
like that i didn't i just did open mics
and i didn't like go i think like the
best thing to do would just to be doing
shows just yeah i'm gonna do stand up
for
an hour and it might be good it might be
bad but i'm gonna do it every week and
then people will start coming i mean in
mine it's like it's not just stand up
and i've been working on it for a really
long time but like it's definitely in
other stand-ups when they like see that
you're doing [ __ ] they're like oh that's
really cool i'm like yeah you can
literally do whatever you want i mean
i'm lucky that i have like
my director and producer and [ __ ] but i
still had to like put feelers out for
that and then like once people starts
like i get the most opportunities when i
am putting on the most for myself
because once people start seeing you do
[ __ ] they're like oh that person's doing
[ __ ] i want to be a part of that and
it's like people put all this producing
work into like showcases too it's like
you could be working on your half hour
and getting those people out for that
too
like building your own following yeah
that's just the most easiest way to do
it is showcases it's the way that
everyone does it
yeah
she's still eating her sausage i know
uh no i don't think she's gonna throw up
but i've also never given her human food
so
hans just gave my disabled dog human
human
food
what is this human food have you seen
rick and morty or like yes
um but yeah i don't want to just quote
yeah it's like it's so lame
especially rick and morty
love i like i often watch tv in a long
while though because like i don't like
to have them
i like have a tv you know
um i mean the phone's pretty yeah so
like we can hang out until the show that
i'm kind of on but you're most
definitely on
yeah
i'm supposed to go to a show at eight
you want to drive me um can i get a spot
what show is it
um
will you ask if i can do a guest spot
because i love you yeah
yeah text i'll text him
ryan joseph is hitting me up
april 15th and stuff
oh god i hate the calendar up
uh sorry it's okay april 15th i can't
16th i can't
29th 30th i can't
i told them which days i can do it
for what
for the show
which show are you booking right now
um
i'm doing booking
[Music]
a show it hyenas
um but yeah i mean
i like ryan joseph it's just the way
that he books shows and communicates
sometimes is very is he an awesome
manipulative yeah sometimes
is he still la
yeah he just
does um
[Music]
he does both
it's so frustrating
he communicates to me like through like
fifth like three different apps so i
gotta find the one i like can't help but
read these comments but they're really
stupid
they're like every vet comic would do
the show it's about my time
it's literally not
i can
i got to stop reading these comments i
don't care about this
do you want to read the comments
no they're just upset about me canceling
my show that's why
they think you should do all the shows
all the time no yeah that's that's a
false way to look at that's what every
bad comedian thinks it's like go up
every night even if it's just a shitty
mic and it makes you hate your material
and then you're worse and you're three
steps back
yeah i mean your emotional health is
very important especially you because
you're so sensitive uh yeah definitely
and i my show's about something that's
sensitive so it's not really like a
great thing to share with like only a
couple people
where the energy is really awkward
um but yeah i mean i think that they
don't know what it's like to do a show
and for them it's just all like you know
they only see the positive side of doing
it they say blow your nose babe like i
just like i was just sick and i'm
congested oh do they think that i have
[ __ ] snot on my nose right now
yeah i'm just [ __ ] sick and i have a
septum ring wait so what show are you
doing at eight
um that's some brewery can you ask if i
can go up
sure
let me ask
um i think that it's good to not do
shows i mean i like i i was
in a mindset where i was doing all the
shows all the time so
yeah and then that makes you tired and
hate things
and then you're worse at it
i said no worries if not
because i don't want to no worries if
not uh although
i won't be able to get there because she
won't drive me oh
oh no
i gotta touch her
yeah that's okay
hans is molesting my disabled dog right
now
oh she's like really tangled in it
okay i got it
jump
[ __ ] no i'm tangling it it's just
[ __ ] surprised
your whole response
this is like
ever since we got back
it's not been a podcast
it's just been us like on the phone
um
but
how do you feel about austin
i love austin
i was like thinking about whatever
happens with my show after fringe um
and then like where i'll land and i'm
like i definitely just think it's like
smart to split time here
la
and new york but if
it's really just dependent on my show so
would you say austin's the third
or the second i mean i think austin's
the second because there's not enough
stage time in la
but la's definitely more
established and also i have more
stitches
like i have like family like not my
family but like friends that are like
feel like i don't know though because
you're from southern california
yeah but not my actual family that's out
there like my homies but also my homies
are here
yeah
yeah it's like really bad how much i
love it here
it's good this is a good city and we're
making it it's not me
you want me to move here i kind of do
yeah i mean i don't have a lot of
friends and
we're good friends now i don't have to
make another one
i have one
but i think it's a good city because
it's being made it's new it's fresh it's
not like you just have to kiss ass here
it's definitely innovative yeah um
the only thing is there's not a lot of
industry for
the other stuff
yeah like acting tv and acting and [ __ ]
like that
yeah what are you gonna do
you can't fake it and lie i'm gonna
build hollywood from the ground up in
austin texas why don't you
act right now you want to do a sketch
yeah should we do a sketch yeah give me
like a topic
uh have you seen that adam driver movie
with scarlett johansson marriage story
yeah you just want to reenact the
marriage story
yeah i don't really really remember i
feel like it
all of it better okay okay
so you're adam driver i assume hey uh
where's charlie our child child that we
had together
where where is he i got a it's my
visitation um they took him away
what
you're supposed to tell me when these
things happen i they took him away and i
didn't have my cell phone with me
because i have a jitterbug and it died
what the [ __ ] is a jitterbug
haven't you seen the commercials for the
jitterbug
why he's getting so animated about
explaining jitterbug
i mean either she's happy
love me we're supposed to be in a
marriage i thought we were divorced oh
[ __ ] are we
who took charlie our boy
the
it's a
child's
child's protective services
took charlie okay
because it's an attack you're a [ __ ] dad
and you weren't around
i'm here right now to pick him up i mean
i want to be a good dad 10 minutes late
so i called protective services
okay fine okay if you want to use our
child's well-being as a weapon against
me
um
you know that just means you're a bad
person and i'm better than you
oh i love you
oh i love you too that's really sweet
that you said that we should we should
uh we should go have sex in the bedroom
and then um
and then cheat on each other afterwards
yeah i'm down for that because i have a
lot of [ __ ] lined up
even with that weird looking face adam
driver
yeah people like my lumpy face
they also like how
i have a deep voice and i sound like
andre the giant
um
yeah i'm like
i'm like taken aback right now wait can
we just like end scene for a second
you're a really good actor what are you
talking about oh my god that did you
feel like did you get goosebumps did you
feel the electric energy in this room
yeah i felt authentic and meisner-ish
yeah do you know you know what meisner
is yeah isn't it where you like do
method acting um
yeah i really like i really saw you as
adam driver
i had a driver playing another character
no yeah you were just playing it did
they like it
thumbs up
best carbonation
in the game i tried to replicate it with
a soda stream and it was weak
you're like not like paying attention at
all like what the [ __ ]
why are we even this hot if they're not
paying attention okay let's do another
scene let's do another scene okay um
this one will be uh
let's see
uh you're you
just got diagnosed with cancer but uh oh
uh
this is your third time and you feel
kind of okay about it and go
and you have to tell me and i'm uh you
could make me whoever you want
hey mom
hey honey how was the doctor that you
brought yourself to
the doctor that i
transported myself to independently of
you was very helpful and kind and he
also told me i have uh ulcerative
colitis
for the third time
it's
it's a lot i know
honey it's not just a lot it's
it's everything this house is riddled
with cancer
i'm sorry that i brought cancer into
this house mom i feel like a death i
swear to god i'm gonna ground you again
for getting cancer for the third time
i deserve it i'm a sick boy you're a
dirty little cancer boy
i'm a dirty dirty little [ __ ] cancer
[ __ ] oh
honey don't talk to your mother that way
mom i really am sorry that i have cancer
and i will really try harder sorry sorry
sorry that's all i hear from you these
days huh it's
okay well when am i gonna see action
when am i gonna see you in remission
um the doctor said maybe after an
aggressive round of chemotherapy i will
uh you know start to get better
but you never know with cancer it could
spread
it could spread yeah to the lymph nodes
to other people
yeah oh so now your cancer is contagious
yeah i got contagious cancer so 14 year
olds are so selfish they just
go go go and bring home cancer
contagious contagious cancer
i'm sorry i'll uh try to get
non-contagious cancer next time it's
like cooties but um it's like you catch
cancer
oh don't let me get you with the cancer
again on the playground i told you to
knock that [ __ ] off i got cancer today
it was very uncomfortable
they started replicating my cells
and then i couldn't stop it and the kids
were just like look at him he's got
cancer now and i was like oh
it's you know like you guys did this to
me and i feel bad now and i have cancer
i couldn't stop it from happening
did you get a message back
um
no
i said someone just sending you nudes
who's calling me
um
okay now give me one
okay
so
we are
um you know
on
mars and we're astronauts and there's
like something going on and
you know the flaps are flaps aren't
flapping
we're southern yeah
hey you check out the goddamn flaps on
the mars rover damn it these flaps ain't
flapping and we're on [ __ ] goddamn
mars
it's too much
too far away from home i'll miss alabama
i miss bama where flaps were supposed to
be flapping and now we took ourselves up
to the
[ __ ] moon and now them flaps are not
flapping
i wish they were but you know
there's
there's a lot of flaps that aren't
flapping
and what are you gonna do about it huh
big tough guy with the with the seven
gallon
hat
astronaut [ __ ]
not flap
imma go outside and try to fix it with
my
wrench and i'm going to go around and
sort of holler at it and try to
you know throw a lasso on it and try to
hump it into flapping again
just like i did your mother
ayo
ayo brother even in space you still you
still goddamn got it
we're a couple cut space cowboys
shooting the [ __ ] and [ __ ] making it
work america [ __ ] chewing tobacco in
space they said i couldn't do it and i
stained my mouth up here
all that gravity's got me feeling like i
need to take a [ __ ]
oh
hey stomach what's wrong with you upset
i hear you i feel that way too it's
probably all that tobacco the best
challenge it does
you're not now
i feel like he got some butterflies
stomach
and scene
i think that one was our best yet yeah
we should put it on we should have a
character podcast yeah
should do the whole podcast and
character
uh who am i
i'm just uh i'm a [ __ ] little hey girl
it's like a little hey girl
yeah i just [ __ ] love hay and i love
sitting on it and i love chewing on hay
you are a hay [ __ ]
hans you took too long to respond i
think you're like processing how hot
hey sloth was
that sounds painful
uh
what you love hay
can't get enough of this hay yeah i
can't stop
shoving hay up my [ __ ]
well i know i got more where that came
from i got some hay of my [ __ ]
i think we should stop
are we in a fever dream now
you completely lost touch with reality
or untethered and flying in space i feel
yeah i feel like i feel like on a
different planet now
we are we're back on mars
yeah i mean it is kind of a [ __ ] up
reality i'm living and i never thought i
would be in your room
in austin texas
when i first met you i met you in a van
in new york city so
this is weird
but i
mean you
probably wouldn't think it's weird that
you're in a friend's
room
you know that you met you know like so
it's in a friend's room yeah it's like
eventually you if i told you hey one day
you're going to be in a friend's room
you're probably and
in austin texas i'd be like [ __ ] off and
there's going to be an incredible
pandemic yeah you're going to scatter us
to the wind and then austin texas is
going to become a booming city yeah
and the rednecks are going to get mad at
us for bringing culture and intelligence
into their backwards
they get mad
no some some of them do
but austin is already known for liberals
so it's hard for them to get mad at more
liberals
someone once told me like four years ago
that i'd like austin and i was like what
what do you mean and they're like it's
like a cute city and i was like texas
what's
cute in texas like a big old cow
with big old cow nipples that you just
yank at with a little shirt
cactus
beautiful cute desert
hey feva
i think hey fever i think texas is great
um i think that they're kind of going
all in on the whole republican thing
with the abortion and the trans stuff i
love that they're just like we're
like we want to be involved in every
little thing that has nothing to do with
us
yeah they're like we are
dictating culture too we have too much
time on our hands because uh we have old
money that was passed down to us or
maybe they don't maybe it's the people
who are like
all i have is my farm and my opinions
yeah that's most of them and then the
rich ones get to uh
tell the idiots what to think
but um on chapeau trap house they were
like houston looks like a city that was
designed by oil
like oil gained sentience and it was
like a burgle gurgling little thing like
highways everywhere you want to go buy
me a cowboy hat i would wear a cowboy
hat all night you want to go
buy a cowboy hat and then go to the show
yeah am i getting up
probably not
why because he hasn't responded yeah but
maybe when we get there i can also ask
and in the cowboy hat in the cowboy hat
they're definitely gonna throw me a
guest spot if i'm in a cowboy hat that'd
be [ __ ] stupid if they looked at the
cowboy hat and said sorry no guest spot
yeah sorry it doesn't look like you do
comedies it seems like you're a
character actor
i just get up there in five minutes i'm
a cowboy
like puns what the [ __ ]
i need a place and an object
can someone give me a word to work with
someone screams anal
uh i i've done a lot of that in my day
hey
am i right brother
yeah
howdy fist and howdy mother
trucker
okay let's get out of here okay thanks
guys bye
[Music]
so fun